صحيفه فاينانشال تايمز كتبت عن اعلان
بايدن مقتل جنود امريكيين في هجوم استهدف
قاعده عسكريه بالاردن وعلقت بالقول انها
المره الاولى التي يقتل فيها جنود
امريكيون منذ بدايه الحرب بين اسرائيل
وحماس في غزه مذكره بان الجهود العسكريه
الامريكيه المتزايده في المنطقه اثارت
مخاوف من امكانيه جر الولايات المتحده
وحلفائها الى حرب اقليميه اوسع
نطاقه ابرز تقرير في صحيفه الوس جون
تحذيرات الامم المتحده من انعكاسات اعلان
دول تعليقها تمويل الاونروا على سكان قطاع
غزه ينبه التقرير الى ان الامم المتحده
تعتمد في ازمات اخرى عبر العالم على
وكالات متعدده تنشط على الارض لكن الوضع
في غزه مختلف تماما فونر هي الوكاله
الوحيده العامله هناك وسيكون من الصعب على
جهه اخرى تابعه للامم المتحده تعويض دورها
في ظرف وجيز بينما الصراع مستمر
يرى مقال بصحيفه الجارديان في حكم العدد
الدوليه دعوه
[موسيقى]
لصحوة العدل
الدوليه نشرت صحيفه النيويورك تايمز
تقريرا يقول ان الاسلحه التي استخدمتها
القوات الاسرائيليه لفرض الحصار على غزه
تستخدم الان ضدها ويوضح التقرير بالاشاره
الى ان جزءا كبيرا من الاسلحه التي
استخدمتها حماس في هجوم السابع من اكتوبر
ومنذ بدايه الحرب مصدره الجيش الاسرائيلي
نفسه ذكر التقرير ان المعلومات
الاستخباراتيه الاسرائيليه اظهرت مدى قدره
حماس على بناء الصواريخ والاسلحه المضاده
للدبابات بالاعتماد على الاف الذخائر غير
المنفجره التي اطلقتها اسرائيل باتجاه غزه
وقدرتها حتى على الوصول الى القواعد
العسكريه الاسرائيليه وسارقه اسلحه
منها نقرا في بوليتيكو تحت عنوان ازمه
البحر الاحمر تضرب تجاره اوروبا للمواد
الغذائيه الطازجه في الصحيفه حديث عن تعطل
شحنات المواد سريعه التلف بسبب هجمات
الحوثيين عندما دخل الحوثيون على خط في
الشرق الاوسط كان القاده الاوروبيون
يتخوفون من ضرر قد يلحق بامداد الطاقه
وبعد ثلاثه اشهر تحذر شركات التصدير
والشحن الاوروبيه من ضرر متزايد يمس تجاره
الفواكه والخضراوات
[موسيقى]